From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. I've been talking to people lately about their jobs. Something is going on with jobs right now. People are leaving them, they want to leave them, where we do our jobs is changing, what we do. And I've been especially interested in people who are designated essential workers. I think for the stay at home types, people like me, our jobs changed in very obvious ways. But for people who continued to go to work in person, their jobs changed too, but those changes were sometimes less visible.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是 Chana Joffe-Walt，代替 Ira Glass 主持。最近我一直在和人们聊他们的工作。现在的就业环境很微妙。人们在辞职，他们想辞职，我们工作的地方在变，我们做的工作内容也在变。我特别关注那些被称为“必要行业员工”的人。我觉得对于像我这样居家办公的人来说，工作方式的改变显而易见。但对于那些坚持去现场上班的人来说，他们的工作也变了，只是这些变化有时不那么显眼。
For example, Kerry Breen. He's a carpenter, works for the New York City Department of Education fixing things in schools. Spring last year when all the schools shut down for COVID, Kerry wasn't sure what that meant for him until he heard no, no, no, he should still come in, report to work.
比如 Kerry Breen。他是一名木匠，为纽约市教育局工作，负责学校里的维修事务。去年春天，当所有学校因疫情关闭时，Kerry 不确定这意味着什么，直到他接到通知说不不不，他还是得去上班，去报到。
Well, the fact that they deemed us essential I kind of found it a little comical in the beginning. That door has creaked for years, that floor has creaked for years. All of a sudden, today it's an emergency, or it's essential.
好吧，起初他们把我们定为“必要行业员工”，我觉得这有点滑稽。那扇门吱吱作响好几年了，那块地板也吱吱作响好几年了。突然之间，今天它就变成紧急情况，或者是“必要”的了。
It's not like he was a doctor or a grocery store worker.
他又不是医生或超市员工。
Most of our work is repairing floors, doors, ceilings that are down, bathrooms falling apart.
我们大部分工作是维修地板、门、破损的吊顶，还有翻修洗手间。
Do you have a favorite sort of task? Like on Monday morning if you get assigned doors are you like, ugh, more doors? Or is there one that you really like?
你有特别喜欢的任务吗？比如周一早上如果被分配去修门，你会觉得“哎，又是门？”还是说有什么是你特别喜欢的？
I wouldn't say there's a favorite. My favorite is when the building has an elevator. Because you'll get doors on the fifth floor of a building, and you've got to carry doors that weigh potentially a couple of pounds up and then back down.
谈不上最喜欢什么。我最喜欢的是那栋楼里有电梯。因为如果你得去五楼修门，你得扛着几磅重的门上楼，然后再扛下来。
Kerry is practical in this way. Kerry has been a carpenter for 35 years. He's also a volunteer firefighter, Irish, talks about his kids a lot. So he's going to work, and they're getting a lot done, because there's no kids around.
Kerry 在这方面很务实。Kerry 当了35年的木匠。他还是名志愿消防员，爱尔兰裔，很爱聊他的孩子。所以他去上班，他们完成了很多工作，因为学校里没有孩子。
With the COVID, schools empty, things were getting painted, things were getting fixed. I've never seen the schools look so good.
随着疫情爆发，学校空无一人，到处都在粉刷，到处都在维修。我从未见过学校看起来这么好。
And then April, a couple of weeks after the schools closed, Kerry goes in for his team meeting where they tell everyone what they're working on next.
然后到了四月，学校关闭几周后，Kerry 去参加团队会议，会上告诉大家接下来的工作任务。
It was I believe a Thursday or Friday afternoon. My boss said, we've got a project coming up next week, and we're going to start to build coffins.
我记得那是周四或周五下午。我老板说，下周有个项目，我们要开始做棺材。
He repeated it. We'll be building coffins for the city of New York.
他又重复了一遍。我们要为纽约市制作棺材。
Nobody in the shop believed it. We're like, get out of here. Build coffins. And he produced a set of plans and showed them to us. And he said, we're going to start next week.
车间里没人相信。我们说，别开玩笑了。做棺材？然后他拿出了一套图纸给我们看。他说，我们下周开始。
Monday morning, Kerry goes to work.
周一早上，Kerry 去上班了。
And we had to go to a high school into a gymnasium that was set up as a rudimentary shop with--
我们得去一所高中的体育馆，那里被布置成了一个简陋的车间，带着——
A high school gymnasium with like, basketball lines on the floor kind of thing?
就是那种地板上有篮球线的普通高中体育馆吗？
Yes, yes. We all get up there, and there was actually a prototype of what we had to build standing--
是的，是的。我们都去了那里，实际上现场立着一个我们要做的原型——
It was an example coffin.
那是一个棺材样本。
Yes, I actually have a picture.
对，我甚至拍了照片。
Oh. Whoa. They showed you that prototype?
哦。哇。他们给你们看了那个原型？
Yes.
是的。
It's a simple box, standing on its end where a person's feet would be. And it's open. The cover isn't attached yet, it's just leaning against the box. In the background, you can see a scoreboard, a basketball net, and a championship banner.
那是个简单的盒子，在放脚的一端竖着。它是打开的。盖子还没装上，只是靠在盒子边上。背景里你可以看到计分板、篮球网和冠军旗帜。
And it was a basic plywood and 2 by 4 box. I've built some strange things over the years, but I've never built a coffin in my life.
那就是个基本的胶合板和木方做的盒子。这些年来我做过很多奇怪的东西，但我这辈子从没做过棺材。
Very quickly, the gym became a workshop. They set up cut stations and assembly stations. Electricians came in to install ventilation fans for all the sawdust. And about 10 carpenters got to work.
很快，体育馆就变成了一个车间。他们设置了切割台和组装台。电工进来安装通风扇来处理锯末。大约10名木匠开始工作。
And we started bringing drafts of plywood, which is 50 sheets at a time. And we had six drafts of plywood and two drafts of 2 by 4s. And they didn't give us an end. But we were just told, this is your job for now. So we started, and we ran through all the material, got more material. Ran through that, got more material. Like, oh my god, they really need this many made?
我们开始运来一批批胶合板，一次50张。我们有六批胶合板和两批木方。他们没说什么时候结束。只是告诉我们，这就是你现在的工作。于是我们开工，用完了所有材料，又领了更多。用完了，又领了更多。就像是，天哪，他们真的需要做这么多吗？
I asked Kerry, did they know where the coffins were going? No. Did the carpenters talk about what the boxes were for? No. We just kept working.
我问 Kerry，他们知道这些棺材要去哪吗？不知道。木匠们有没有讨论过这些盒子是干什么用的？没有。我们只是不停地工作。
We would get up to about 150. And so we had a very large stack of them-- it was almost a wall-- across the gym, from one end to the other.
我们做到了大约150个。所以我们堆了很大一堆——几乎像一堵墙——横跨在体育馆里，从这一头到那一头。
Where do you put 150 coffins in a high school gym?
你把150个棺材放在高中体育馆里，放在哪儿？
Straight across the basketball court, from one end to the other. So--
就横在篮球场上，从一边到另一边。所以——
Like stacked on top of each other?
就像堆叠在一起？
Yes, we'd stack them about five or six high. Until we got pallets, and then we placed 10 on a pallet, shrink wrap them, and I would take a forklift and back them into the elevator. I'd drive them out onto the street and up the street, through the schoolyard, down the next street, and to the back of a tractor trailer. And getting honked at for a forklift that goes too slow.
是的，我们叠了大约五六层高。直到我们有了托盘，然后把10个放在一个托盘上，用塑料膜包好，我就开着叉车把它们倒进电梯。我把它们开到街上，穿过操场，再过一条街，一直开到拖挂式卡车后面。因为叉车速度太慢，我还会被后面的车按喇叭催促。
They're honking at you while you were driving the coffins?
你运送棺材的时候他们还在按你喇叭？
Yes. Yes. And in three weeks of doing it, not one person in the neighborhood ever asked the question, what are those, or what are you doing?
是的。是的。在那三周里，社区里没有一个人问过“那是什么”或者“你们在做什么”。
Were you waiting for somebody to ask you?
你在等有人来问吗？
I found it bizarre that nobody asked. Maybe nobody made the connection, or maybe nobody wanted to make the connection. It just seemed like people were going about their lives, until the final load where one guy who spoke Spanish only walks past me, and he just says, "morte," and makes sort of a slicing motion across his neck. And I just said, "si." And he shook his head and just walked away.
我觉得没人问这事很奇怪。也许没人把这事联系起来，或者也许没人愿意去联系。人们似乎都在过着自己的生活，直到最后一次运货时，一个只会说西班牙语的人从我身边走过，他只是说了句“死亡”，然后做了一个割喉的手势。我只是回了句“是的”。他摇了摇头，走开了。
In the end, Kerry's team built 415 coffins. There were carpenters in other schools too. All together, they built 1,400. As I've been talking to people about their jobs, people in lots of different jobs that were deemed essential over these last 17 months, I will very regularly find myself saying something like this.
最终，Kerry 的团队一共做了415口棺材。其他学校也有木匠在做。加起来，他们一共做了1400口。最近我一直在和人们聊他们的工作，聊那些在过去17个月里被视为“必要岗位”的人，我经常会不由自主地说出这样的话。
I had no idea that happened.
我根本不知道发生过这种事。
Well, you wouldn't.
嗯，你当然不知道。
Yeah. Do people--
是啊。人们——
Nobody did.
没人知道。
--know that that happened?
——知道发生过这种事吗？
It was not for public knowledge. I think nobody knew how to handle it. I'm sure the schools didn't want like, hey, we're building coffins over here. It's not something you want to highlight. But now that things are waning and-- all right, you can kind of let that out.
这不是公开的信息。我想没人知道该怎么处理。我肯定学校不想让外界知道“嘿，我们这儿在做棺材”。这可不是你想大肆宣传的事。但现在情况好转了，你可以稍微透露一下了。
Yeah. There's this sort of-- part of what's weird about what just happened is that there were people who had to do things that just normally are never asked of in your job. And it wasn't a war. But if it was a war, and after a war--
是的。发生这种事最诡异的地方在于，有些人不得不做一些工作中从没要求做过的事。虽然不是战争。但如果这是一场战争，战后——
Yeah, yeah. It's logistics.
没错，没错。这就是物流。
--you go over what happened. Yeah.
——你会回顾发生的一切。是的。
Exactly. This is how many people died. This is how many planes we built or trucks we-- whatever.
没错。这就是死亡人数。这就是我们制造了多少飞机或卡车——什么的。
Or the fact that somebody built coffins in a high school gym in the Bronx.
或者有人在布朗克斯的一所高中体育馆里制造棺材这件事。
Yeah. There's going to be an accounting. And it'll be the weird stats that come out of somewhere. And this is one of the stranger ones.
是的。总会有一个盘点。到时候奇怪的统计数据会冒出来。这是其中最奇怪的一项。
415 coffins. Mark it down. That happened. A year and a half ago, we asked more than 50 million Americans to continue going to work, because they had essential jobs. And they did. Nurses and doctors and also mail carriers and waitresses and construction workers, child care workers, garbage collectors all worked through this once in a century emergency.
415口棺材。记下来。这件事发生过。一年半前，我们要求超过5000万美国人继续上班，因为他们从事的是必要工作。他们确实去了。护士、医生，还有邮递员、女招待、建筑工人、托儿所员工、垃圾收集员，都在这次百年一遇的紧急状态下坚持工作。
And now, we're kind of used to it. We're focused on what's next. But do we even know what just happened? I remember calling to check in on someone early in the pandemic. She works in customs at the airport, and she told me they hadn't gotten any PPE yet, and they were nervous. They all sat right next to each other in desks in this office. So they took cardboard boxes and put them up between their desks. And then they cut holes in the boxes, so they could talk to each other.
现在，我们似乎习以为常了。我们专注于接下来要做什么。但我们真的知道刚刚发生了什么吗？我记得疫情初期曾打电话询问某个人。她在机场海关工作，她告诉我他们还没领到个人防护装备（PPE），大家都非常紧张。他们在那间办公室里桌子挨着桌子坐着。于是他们找来纸箱竖在桌子中间。然后把纸箱挖出孔，这样他们就能对话了。
I had the same feeling hearing that as I did with the coffins. Do people know that happened? Shouldn't we be marking that in some way? 415 coffins, that happened. And 22 jerry-rigged cardboard partitions in JFK airport, that happened too.
听到那个故事时，我的感觉和听到棺材的故事时一模一样。人们知道发生过这些吗？我们难道不该以某种方式铭记吗？415口棺材，那件事发生过。肯尼迪机场里那22个东拼西凑的纸板隔断，那件事也发生过。
Today's show, I'd like to attempt to do a kind of accounting, not of how many people died or how many are unemployed, but a different kind of national accounting of all the smaller private moments that unfolded in people's jobs all across the country-- Maine, Arizona, Michigan, New York City, specifically, essential workers. We're going to hear the stories only they know, moments that changed the way people thought about their jobs, changed the choices they'll make next, and will affect the economy in ways we are only just beginning to see. That's today's show. Stay with us.
今天的节目，我想尝试做一个盘点，不是关于多少人死亡或多少人失业，而是对全国各地——缅因州、亚利桑那州、密歇根州、纽约市——那些“必要行业员工”工作中发生的细小私密瞬间进行一种全国性的盘点。我们将听到只有他们自己知道的故事，那些改变了人们对工作看法、改变了他们未来选择，并将以我们才刚刚开始察觉的方式影响经济的时刻。这就是今天的节目。请留在我们身边。
Because today's show is a kind of audit, each act name will include a number. So our first number for our ledger here is the number 3.
因为今天的节目就像一场审计，每个单元的名字都会包含一个数字。所以我们账本上的第一个数字是3。
This act is called "Three Bottles of Joy." That'll make sense in a second. So here's a small thing you would have no way of knowing what's happening underground during the pandemic. Station agents in New York City's subway system, the people who sit in booths and sell you tickets or give you directions, they were still going to work every day.
这一单元叫“三瓶 Joy 洗洁精”。一会儿你就明白为什么了。这就是你在疫情期间绝对无法从地面上了解到的小事。纽约地铁系统的车站站务员，那些坐在售票亭里卖票或指路的人，他们每天依然坚持上班。
But most of the public stopped riding the trains, so it got really quiet down there. And as the weeks went on, station agents began bringing items from home into their booths to sit with them during the day-- bibles, spiritual aphorisms.
但大部分公众停止搭乘地铁，所以地下变得非常安静。随着时间推移，站务员开始从家里带些东西放进售票亭，好在白天有个伴——圣经、心灵鸡汤。
Little stuff like that, putting mirrors. Look at you smile.
诸如此类的小东西，还有放镜子。看着自己微笑。
Moneta Lewis.
Moneta Lewis。
We don't get a lot of that.
我们得不到多少关注。
She's a station agent for the MTA--
她是 MTA 的一名站务员——
From management, we don't get a lot of that.
从管理层那里，我们得不到多少关注。
--New York City transit. She saw workers bringing in all sorts of things into their booths.
——纽约市交通局。她看到工人们往售票亭里带各种各样的东西。
At one point, we was buying the bottles of Joy. Sometimes we would have them sitting up, Joy.
有段时间，我们在买 Joy 洗洁精。有时我们会把它们摆在那儿，Joy。
Joy, like the dishwashing soap?
Joy，像那个洗洁精品牌？
Yeah. So if you see the word joy, you look at, it's going to make you smile.
是的。所以如果你看到“Joy”（喜悦）这个词，看着它，会让你微笑。
Moneta says, we needed that. Made us feel less alone.
Moneta 说，我们需要那个。让我们感到不那么孤独。
Over time, the bottles of Joy, they started to be a marker for Moneta of how their work was changing. Moneta's job is to be lunch relief for other station agents. That means she travels to a station, the agent on duty goes on lunch, and Moneta sits in their booth for 30 minutes, then travels to the next station. So she sees the inside of a lot of booths. And Moneta's an observer. Black woman, cat-eye glasses. She can talk to anyone, and she does.
渐渐地，这些 Joy 洗洁精瓶子成了 Moneta 的一种标志，代表着他们的工作正在如何改变。Moneta 的工作是为其他站务员提供午餐替换。这意味着她要赶到一个车站，值班站务员去吃午饭，Moneta 在他们的岗亭里坐30分钟，然后去下一个车站。所以她看过很多岗亭的内部。Moneta 是个观察者。黑人女性，戴着猫眼眼镜。她能和任何人聊天，而且她确实也这么做。
She goes from South Ferry station to Rector to Chambers. She gets a bagel from the corner store at 10:30 AM. She eats it for six minutes by the window as she narrates the traffic at the four-way intersection outside. With an eye on the unmarked cop car that is always parked there waiting, she says, four or five tickets daily.
她从南码头站赶到雷克托站，再到钱伯斯站。她会在早上10点半去拐角的店买个贝果。她一边盯着外面十字路口的交通，一边在那儿吃六分钟贝果。她盯着那辆一直停在那里待命的无标志警车，她说，每天都有四五张罚单。
And people cut the light, because you could cut the light four ways here. Every day.
而且人们会闯红灯，因为这里四面都可以闯红灯。每天都这样。
Then it's underground. Moneta waves me into the subway through the gate. Come on, you're with the MTA lady.
然后就是下到地下。Moneta 挥手示意让我通过闸机进入地铁。“来吧，你和 MTA 女士在一起。”
You're with me. You're with the MTA lady.
“你和我在一起。你和 MTA 女士在一起。”
March 2020, when the pandemic shut down New York City, Moneta brought word of the virus from booth to booth. At one booth, the agent would say, do you think we should be wearing masks? And at the next booth, oh, I heard we're not supposed to. Management doesn't want us scaring the customers. Another booth, what customers? Moneta says all the agents at every booth were talking about the disappearing customers.
2020年3月，当疫情封锁纽约市时，Moneta 把病毒的消息从一个岗亭传到另一个岗亭。在一个岗亭，员工会说：“你觉得我们该戴口罩吗？”在下一个岗亭，“哦，我听说我们不应该戴。管理层不想让我们吓到顾客。”再下一个岗亭，“哪有什么顾客？”Moneta 说，每个岗亭的员工都在谈论那些消失的顾客。
Absolutely. We was, like they get to stay home? We wanted them to close the station down too. But as station agents, we had to be here on set. Yeah, so we felt a little cheated. We felt like, OK, what about us? So what are y'all going to-- We grateful to have a job, don't get me wrong. I have acquired quite a lot, even just meeting people and learning. But it was just like an uneasiness. It was like we was coming to work to get sick.
当然。我们就在想，他们能待在家里？我们也想让他们把车站关了。但作为站务员，我们必须到岗。是的，所以我们觉得自己有点被亏待了。我们觉得，那我们呢？你们打算怎么安排——感谢上帝我有份工作，别误会。我收获了很多，甚至只是通过遇见人们并学习。但这就像是一种不安。就像我们每天上班是为了去染上病一样。
You felt like you were coming to work to get sick?
你觉得你是每天上班去染病的？
Yes.
是的。
And they did. Transit workers began to get sick in large numbers. And they began to die in large numbers-- first a subway conductor and a bus driver, then a track worker. The MTA suffered more COVID deaths than any other agency in New York City, 171 deaths. COVID was surging, and New York City was the epicenter. It was like a plague struck this one specific agency.
事实也的确如此。公交系统员工开始大面积患病。他们开始大面积死亡——先是一名地铁列车员和一名巴士司机，然后是铁路工人。MTA 遭遇了纽约市所有机构中最多的新冠死亡病例，171人死亡。疫情肆虐，而纽约市是中心。就像一场瘟疫袭击了这一个特定的机构。
A bus driver I spoke with told me, when you lose someone in the transit system, you notice. Because what transit is is a time schedule. That train pulls out at 4:31 every day. That bus passes with the same bus driver at 8:22 every morning. That person buys chips from the same vending machine in the break room at exactly 5:12. When someone dies, their absence is immediately visible.
我采访的一位巴士司机告诉我，当你在交通系统里失去一个人时，你是会察觉到的。因为交通就是时间表。那趟列车每天4点31分驶离。那辆巴士每天早上8点22分准时经过，司机也是同一个。那个人每天正好5点12分在休息室的自动售货机买薯片。当有人去世，他们的缺席是立竿见影的。
Moneta told me she felt like suddenly work was a battle and she was a soldier trying to stay alive. A lot of transit workers felt this way. But they are not soldiers. So I would ask people, how do you make that switch? How does a person go from driving a train every day to going into work thinking you might die doing this job?
Moneta 告诉我，她觉得工作突然变成了一场战斗，而她是一个试图活下去的士兵。许多交通系统员工都有这种感觉。但他们并不是士兵。所以我问人们，你是怎么完成这种心理转变的？一个人怎么能从每天开着火车，转变为去上班时认为自己可能会死在工作岗位上？
The week that COVID hit my line and my terminal, I was on vacation.
疫情袭击我的线路和终点站的那一周，我正在休假。
Christopher Gonsalves drives the number 7 train. He's a conductor, suddenly an essential conductor, which he spoke about like he was being conscripted into an army just as the war was heating up.
Christopher Gonsalves 开的是7号线列车。他是一名列车员，突然变成了“必要岗位列车员”，他谈起这个就像是在战争白热化时被征召入伍一样。
I just kept looking at my text messages and Facebook. Everybody at work was getting sick. And I said, wow. And I started getting worried when it was time to go back to work. I didn't want to go back. I was just thinking about it. I called my mom a lot. And I told her, I said, Ma, guess what? The week I took off, everyone got sick. And she was over here thanking the Lord. I was like, OK, Ma, I got it. Thank you, appreciate it. But I still got to go to work tomorrow.
我一直在看我的短信和 Facebook。单位里每个人都病了。我说，哇。而当该回去上班时，我开始担心。我不想回去。我一直在想这件事。我给妈妈打了很多电话。我告诉她，我说：“妈，你猜怎么着？我休假的那周，大家都病倒了。”她在电话那头感谢上帝。我说：“好的，妈，我知道了。谢谢，感激不尽。”但我明天还得去上班。
And she's giving me the whole thing-- please be careful, wear your mask, stay far away from everybody. I said, yes, I know. And She's. Also getting on me for my vitamins. She said the vitamins is going to help. Take the vitamins. And I said, yes, Ma, I will.
她不停地叮嘱我——请一定要小心，戴好口罩，和所有人保持距离。我说：“是的，我知道。”她还逼我吃维生素。她说维生素会有用的。一定要吃。我说：“好的，妈，我会的。”
Chris said his mom told him, no, no, no, do it now while we're on the phone. And then she waited until she could hear him taking his vitamins.
Chris 说他妈妈让他现在就吃，就在电话通着的时候。然后她一直等着，直到能听到他吃下维生素的声音。
And I was worried. And I said, Mom. I spoke to her just to tell her you're my beneficiary. If something happens, everything is set. I have life insurance. Don't worry about it. So she was worried, and I just had to calm her down a bit.
我很担心。我对她说：“妈，我刚跟她说了你是我的人寿保险受益人。如果发生什么事，一切都安排好了。我有保险。别担心。”她很焦虑，我不得不稍微安抚她一下。
You told her, "you're my beneficiary," that was your way of calming her down?
你告诉她“你是我的人寿保险受益人”，这就是你安抚她的方式？
Well, she tells it to me all the time when she flies on airplanes. Yeah. It was scary but relieving. It was very relieving when I was talking to her, because she's my mother. I just had to man up and go in the next day. I didn't want to.
嗯，她每次坐飞机时也会这样跟我说。是的，很害怕，但也很宽慰。当我跟她说话时，感觉很宽慰，因为她是我妈妈。我只是不得不振作起来，第二天去上班。但我真的不想去。
Moneta told me it was around this time when you'd hear about people dying daily that station agents started bringing in the bottles of Joy dish soap into their booths.
Moneta 告诉我，就在这期间，当你每天听到有人死亡时，站务员们开始把 Joy 洗洁精瓶子带进岗亭。
Transit workers were essential. But they were also alone. Station agents are supposed to be the eyes and ears of the subway system. But there were so few people.
交通系统员工是“必要”的。但他们也很孤独。站务员本应是地铁系统的眼睛和耳朵。但人太少了。
Transit took away cash purchases-- fear of transmission. So subway fares were all taken on machines. Moneta was by herself sitting in the booths, looking at all the hopeful items people brought, in the bottles of Joy, and just hanging on until we got to the other side. And now, here we are, kind of at the other side? Is there another side?
交通局取消了现金购票——因为担心传染。所以地铁票全是用机器买的。Moneta 独自一人坐在岗亭里，看着人们带来的那些充满希望的小物件，看着那些 Joy 瓶子，只是苦苦支撑直到我们走出困境。现在，我们到了这里，算是走出了困境吗？有另一边吗？
Things have definitely changed underground. They're better. But Moneta's job is not the same. The people have not returned. They're not riding the trains like before. And the cash hasn't returned either. Station agents still are not allowed to take cash purchases.
地下情况确实改变了。好转了。但 Moneta 的工作还是不一样了。人还没回来。他们不像以前那样坐火车了。现金也没回来。站务员依然不允许收取现金。
Technically, we sit there. We're not supposed to be on our phones, not supposed to be reading anything outside of transit memos. We have no customers. So where is that-- I think it's in England-- where the soldiers just sit there, they don't move, no--
按规定，我们坐在那里。我们不被允许玩手机，不被允许阅读除交通通告之外的任何东西。我们没有顾客。所以那是什么——我想是在英国吧——士兵们就那样坐着，一动不动，没有——
Like at the Queen's palace?
就像女王的白金汉宫那样？
Yeah.
对。
Does it make you not want to do the job anymore?
这让你不想再干这份工作了吗？
It makes me feel like I'm unable to fully do what I was hired to do.
这让我感觉我无法完全履行我被雇佣来做的工作。
Say more about that. What do you mean by that?
多说点。你是指什么？
One of the biggest things coming down here was the busyness. I like busy stations. The money, the camaraderie with the customers, they're going to work. I'm a people's person. And most of us were.
在这里工作最棒的事情之一就是那种忙碌感。我喜欢繁忙的车站。金钱、与顾客的友情，他们要去上班。我是一个喜欢交际的人。我们大多数人也是。
You don't feel like a people person anymore.
你不再觉得自己是个喜欢交际的人了。
I do feel like a people person, I just feel like people don't care. And a lot of us feel that way.
我依然觉得我喜欢交际，我只是觉得人们不在乎了。我们很多人都有这种感觉。
Especially because recently, the MTA has proposed eliminating her position, the position of lunch relief for station agents. The union sued, and the MTA backed down. But looking forward, without cash purchases, the job of a station agent does seem much less essential. What if Moneta survived the war only to be laid off in peacetime?
尤其是因为最近 MTA 提议取消她的职位，即站务员的午餐替换岗位。工会提起诉讼，MTA 退缩了。但展望未来，在没有现金交易的情况下，站务员的工作看起来确实没那么必要了。如果 Moneta 在战争中幸存下来，却在和平时期被裁员了怎么办？
I asked her recently if the bottles of Joy are still in the booths. She said nah, people took them away. You're not allowed to bring extra stuff into the booth. You could get away with it before, when we were left alone down there.
我最近问她那些 Joy 瓶子还在不在岗亭里。她说没在了，人们把它们拿走了。不允许在岗亭里放额外的东西。以前我们独自待在下面时还可以偷偷放，现在不行了。
Act 2. Moneta's job changed pretty dramatically, in ways she did not like. But most jobs didn't actually change that much. In fact, one of the strangest aspects of working through the pandemic for a lot of people was how much did not change in their jobs. That is the case with this next story. So we're going to add another number to our list. If you picture our ledger here, we've got 415 coffins, 3 bottles of joy. I feel like the next number here should have stars drawn around it or something, sparkly pen aspirational stars, like a goals list.
第二单元。Moneta 的工作发生了巨大的变化，以她不喜欢的方式。但大多数工作其实并没有太大变化。事实上，对于许多人来说，在疫情期间工作的最奇怪的一面，就是他们的工作竟然有那么多没变。这就是下一个故事的情况。所以我们要把另一个数字加入我们的清单。如果我们想象一下我们的账本，我们有415口棺材，3瓶 Joy 洗洁精。我觉得下一个数字应该画上星星，闪闪发光的笔写出的愿望星，就像目标清单一样。
The number is 25. Act 2 is called "The $25 Tip." It took Shelly Ortiz a decade in the restaurant business to work up to a $25 tip. She started when she was 15 years old, got her first job as a cashier at a Five Guys in Phoenix. And Shelly walks in bubbly, ready to go. Her nickname growing up was Smiley, and you can hear it in her voice.
数字是25。第二单元叫“25美元的小费”。Shelly Ortiz 在餐饮业干了十年，才熬到能拿到25美元的小费。她15岁就开始工作了，第一份工作是菲尼克斯一家 Five Guys 的收银员。Shelly 总是充满活力，整装待发。她小时候的昵称叫“笑脸”，你能从她的声音里听出来。
I remember I was at orientation, and I really wanted to make friends. I remember turning to a man and being like, so what high school do you go to? And he looked at me, and he was like, I'm 35. [LAUGHTER] It was just a big realization that like, I'm the youngest person here, and it shows.
我记得在入职培训时，我真的很想交朋友。我转头对一个男的说：“那你上哪所高中？”他看着我，说：“我35岁了。”（笑声）那一刻我才意识到：我是这里年纪最小的，而且一眼就能看出来。
Shelly describes herself as an all-in type person. And she threw herself into restaurants, all through college, her 20s. There was Five Guys, then a French bistro, a sandwich shop, a food court. And eventually, fine dining, where she finally got her first $25 tip, which was huge. She was only making $9 an hour. Shelly picked up on the routines of each place she worked easily. She loves a routine. And she loved restaurants. Shelly got rude customers all the time, people who would say things about her body, her personality, how much she was checking on the table.
Shelly 说自己是个全力以赴的人。她一头扎进餐饮业，整个大学期间，还有20多岁时。她干过 Five Guys，一家法式小酒馆，一家三明治店，一个美食广场。最终到了高端餐饮，在那里她终于拿到了第一笔25美元的小费，那笔钱数额巨大。当时她时薪才9美元。Shelly 很轻松地就掌握了每个工作场所的流程。她热爱例行公事。而且她热爱餐厅。Shelly 总是遇到粗鲁的顾客，有人会评论她的身材、个性，或者她巡视餐桌的频率。
I remember I used to work brunches a lot. I was like, the brunch girl. And brunch made good money. But brunch clientele, it's intimidating. And I remember we were running out of forks. We were running out of forks. And I think about this all the time. I think I put some spoons on a table, a very picky brunch table. Because they were getting like something that they could potentially eat it with a spoon, but they probably should have actual roll-ups with a fork and a knife and a napkin.
我记得我经常干早午餐。我是那种“早午餐女孩”。早午餐赚得多。但早午餐的客群，很令人生畏。我记得当时我们缺叉子。真的缺。我经常想起这件事。我想我给一张非常挑剔的早午餐桌放了勺子。因为他们点了一些可能可以用勺子吃的东西，但按理说他们应该有配好的叉子、刀和餐巾纸。
And I remember I came back to collect them, because we needed them, and give them actual roll-ups. And a woman slapped my hand away and said, we need those. And I was like, I'm giving you roll-ups, actual silverware. And she looked at her friend. She was like [SIGH]. Like, this girl.
我记得回来收走它们时，因为我们需要这些餐具，得给他们换正式的套装。一个女人一把拍开我的手说：“我们需要这些。”我说：“我是要给你们换正式套装，就是标准的餐具。”她看着她的朋友，叹了口气。就像在说，这姑娘啊。
And she rolled her eyes and continued to talk to the woman. And it was just a reminder that like, I am not a human to her. I have never been a person to her. I am just someone out of her world that doesn't deserve to be treated like a human being.
她翻了个白眼，继续和那个女人说话。这提醒了我：在她眼里，我不是个人。我从来就不是个人。我只是她世界之外的一个什么东西，不配得到人类的对待。
Shelly got it. This too was routine. It came along with the $25 tips.
Shelly 明白了。这也属于例行公事。伴随着那25美元小费一起来的。
I mean, amongst the servers, no one would be shocked to hear that. It's very common.
我是说，在服务员里，没人会对这种事感到震惊。这太常见了。
And it felt worth it to you.
这让你觉得值吗？
Yeah. I would just think that I got her money, I got paid. So she's just another person that I don't have to think about after this. And at the end of my shift, I'd be able to go home. I'd be able to hug my girlfriend. It became like a disassociation. Like, this is not me. This is just this person who is serving, and you're going to take home this money. Take home the money.
是的。我只会想我拿到了她的钱，我被付了工资。所以她只是另一个我不用再想的人。下班后，我就能回家。我就能拥抱我的女朋友。这就成了一种解离。就像，这不是真正的我。这只是那个正在服务的人，而你将会把钱带回家。带走钱，就够了。
She honed this skill to disassociate. She could shake off whatever was thrown at her. Shelly would collect the cash from the table and move on.
她磨练出了这种解离的技能。无论别人怎么对她，她都能抖落掉。Shelly 会收走桌上的钱，然后继续工作。
The mayor of Phoenix declared a state of emergency on March 17, 2020. Shelly's restaurant closed briefly. But soon after, restaurants were declared essential services in Arizona and reopened for takeout and delivery.
菲尼克斯市长于2020年3月17日宣布进入紧急状态。Shelly 的餐厅短暂关闭。但没过多久，餐厅在亚利桑那州被列为“必要服务”，重新开放供外卖和配送。
But Shelly hung back. Her dad was sick, recovering from a heart attack. And her mom is a nurse who was treating patients with COVID. Shelly was too scared. She told me she didn't want to apply for unemployment, because she's Puerto Rican, and she just had a sense that that kind of thing never happened for people like her. By May, restaurants in Arizona were serving people in person, and Shelly had to go back. She was still very nervous.
但 Shelly 在观望。她爸爸生病了，刚从心脏病发作中恢复。她妈妈是一名治疗新冠病人的护士。Shelly 太害怕了。她告诉我她不想申请失业救济，因为她是波多黎各裔，她总觉得那种事从来不会发生在像她这样的人身上。到了五月，亚利桑那州的餐厅开始开放堂食，Shelly 不得不去上班了。她依然非常紧张。
I was double masking before it was even a thing. I bought fake glasses to protect my eyes. I would only really take off my mask to drink water, and I would only drink water in the bathroom where I was alone. That's the only time I would ever get it-- and that was long shifts. I was really scared.
我在那时候还没流行起来时就开始戴双层口罩了。我买了假眼镜来保护眼睛。我只有在喝水时才会摘下口罩，而且我只在厕所独自一人时才喝水。那是唯一一次我会摘口罩的机会——而我的班次很长。我真的很害怕。
Meanwhile, she still had her routines. She was doing all the things she'd done thousands of times before. Welcome the customer, explain the specials, carry the plates, deliver the drinks.
与此同时，她还在照常工作。她重复着成千上万次做过的动作。欢迎顾客、解释特餐、端盘子、送饮料。
And I was just kind of waiting for that shitty thing to happen. I would have people ask me like, pull down your mask. I want to see how much to tip you.
我一直在等着那件烂事发生。有人会问我：“把口罩拉下来。我想看看该给多少小费。”
Pull down your mask, I want to see how much to tip you?
“把口罩拉下来，我想看看该给多少小费？”
Yes.
是的。
Whoa.
哇。
They would want to see how pretty I was before they tipped me.
他们想在给我小费之前看看我有多漂亮。
Was that a thing that happened frequently, that people would ask you to pull down your mask?
这种事发生的频率高吗，就是别人让你拉下口罩？
Yeah. That happened probably about every week. Pull down your mask so I can make sure you're smiling. Pull down your mask so-- or like, why are we still wearing masks? Do you have to wear a mask? It was always about like, either why am I wearing one, or can I see your face?
高。大概每周都会发生。把口罩拉下来让我确定你在微笑。或者——为什么我们还在戴口罩？你必须戴口罩吗？总是围绕着这些话题，要么是为什么我戴着口罩，要么是能不能看看我的脸。
So I can know that you're smiling?
这样我才知道你在笑？
Yeah. So I can know you're smiling, so I can know if you're pretty. [LAUGHS] Which is so stupid. [LAUGHS] It's like, god, who gives a fuck if I'm pretty? Can I just serve you your food?
是的。这样我才知道你在笑，这样我才知道你漂不漂亮。（笑声）这太蠢了。（笑声）就像是，天哪，谁在乎我漂不漂亮？我能给你上菜吗？
I'm sure that wasn't the first time that customers were assessing the way that you looked. But did it feel different to have it stated so baldly?
我相信这肯定不是顾客第一次评估你的外表了。但当他们说得这么直白时，感觉有什么不同吗？
Yeah. So I'm 4 foot 9. I'm very short. And I have very big breasts for my frame. It's unavoidable. I'm very small, I have big boobs. And usually, like-- I'm really cute. So it's easy to just understand that people are going to be checking me out. I would have comments before. But I think when the pandemic hit, it hit harder, because I they wanted me to risk my safety so that they could see if I was cute.
是的。我身高只有4英尺9英寸（约1.45米）。我非常矮。在我的身材比例下，我的胸部很大。这是无法避开的。我很小，我有大胸。通常情况下——我长得很可爱。所以很容易理解人们会盯着我看。我以前也遇到过评论。但我认为当疫情来袭时，这种感觉更强烈了，因为他们想让我冒着生命安全风险，仅仅是为了让他们看看我是否可爱。
Something I heard from a lot of people I talked to about working through a pandemic, people in all sorts of jobs, they said they felt like they were in a movie, that one of the strangest parts was how much did not change. It was uncanny, the way good science fiction is uncanny. It looks like normal life, but something big is off. And the parts of the job that have not changed just make the parts that feel off stand out even more.
我和许多疫情期间上班的人聊过，各行各业的都有，他们说自己感觉像是活在电影里，最诡异的部分是竟有那么多东西没变。这很不可思议，就像好的科幻作品那种不可思议。看着像正常生活，但有什么大事不对劲了。而工作中那些没变的部分，让那些不对劲的感觉显得更加突出。
I was serving a Saturday night, and it was a really busy shift. I was outside, and I was serving this couple. And they were really needy. That wasn't very rare, especially at a restaurant like this where you're paying good money for food and drink. But at the end of the shift, the gentleman-- it was a gentleman and his wife, older gentleman and his wife. And he asked me to pull down my mask, so he could see if the bottom part of my face was as cute as the top. And I said I couldn't.
有天周六晚上，店里非常忙。我在外面，服务一对夫妇。他们要求非常多。这不罕见，尤其是在这种高档餐厅。但在班次结束时，那位男士——那是一位老先生和他的妻子——他让我拉下口罩，好让他看看我脸下半部分是不是和上半部分一样可爱。我说我不能。
And then when I said I couldn't, he said that because he couldn't focus on my face, he was forced to focus on my breasts.
当我拒绝时，他说因为他看不见我的脸，他被迫只能盯着我的胸部看。
Whoa.
哇。
And his wife was sitting right across from him. And I looked at her for any sort of response. And she just kind of gave me a blank stare in return. He said it almost like, matter-of-factly. He was like, well, if I can't look at your face, I'm forced to look at your breasts. And it was just disgusting. It just sucked, which is like, great. Awesome. Now I'm-- I think mostly during the pandemic, my self-worth was so low. I felt really disposable, obviously being objectified all the time, because half my face was covered up.
他妻子就坐在他正对面。我看着她，希望能看到任何反应。她只是给了我一个空白的凝视。他几乎是就事论事地说了出来。他说：“好吧，如果我看不到你的脸，我被迫只能看你的胸部。”这真是太恶心了。这感觉糟透了，不过就是这样。太棒了。现在我——我觉得疫情期间我的自我价值感非常低。我感觉自己真的很可有可无，显然是因为我的半张脸被盖住，一直被客体化。
And I tried to make it work. But I wasn't adjusting the way my coworkers were. And I felt really disposable. And I just felt like another person who was destined to get sick. And it would just be another stat.
我试着去适应。但我并没有像同事们那样去调整心态。我感觉自己真的可以被牺牲。我感觉自己只是另一个注定要生病的人。而这只会成为另一个统计数据。
Have you felt that way before?
你以前有过这种感觉吗？
I've never felt that way before. It was like the pandemic and risking your life and not feeling of camaraderie with your teammates anymore, because it really didn't feel like anyone was taking it as seriously as me. And then I started questioning if I'm this crazy person. And I started questioning my anxiety, and then my anxiety got worse. And the anxiety and the anger got so high. But I felt like I was not adjusting the way my coworkers adjusted. I feel like people who had to work during the pandemic adopted this disassociation, and I couldn't. I couldn't separate it.
我以前从没这样过。就像疫情、冒着生命危险，却不再和队友有那种战友谊了，因为感觉没人像我一样把这件事看得那么严重。然后我开始怀疑自己是不是疯了。我开始怀疑我的焦虑，然后焦虑变得更糟。焦虑和愤怒飙升。但我感觉自己没能像同事们那样调整。我觉得那些在疫情期间上班的人采用了这种解离方式，而我不能。我无法把它分开。
Why couldn't she? Shelly spent so much time on this question. Why couldn't she disassociate as she'd done for years when a customer slapped her hand or yelled or talked about her body? Her coworkers were going out to karaoke after work. Her customers were out with friends and family catching up.
为什么她不能？Shelly 花了很多时间思考这个问题。为什么她不能像过去多年那样，在顾客拍她的手、大叫或谈论她身材时那样去解离？她的同事下班后去唱卡拉OK。她的顾客和朋友家人出去聚会。
I remember one time, a woman had a comment card. And she left it for me. And it said, thanks for making things feel normal. With a smiley face. And I was livid. I was like, things are not normal. This is not normal. I'm risking my life to serve you a margarita, and it's not normal. I don't want to contribute to this fantasy that a pandemic isn't happening right now.
我记得有一次，一个女人带了张意见卡。她留给了我。上面写着：“谢谢你让一切感觉正常。”还画了个笑脸。我简直火冒三丈。我心想，一切都不正常。这根本不正常。我冒着生命危险给你端玛格丽特酒，这不正常。我不想参与这种“现在没发生疫情”的幻象。
That's really interesting. So she was trying to give you a compliment. Like--
这很有意思。所以她是在试着给你赞美。像——
Yeah, and--
是的，而且——
--you did a good job.
——你工作做得不错。
I understand that it was coming from a kind place. But thousands of people are dying right down the road at the hospital. And I'm here serving your margarita, because I have to. Because I have to live. And it was just such an intense moment for me of realization that like, this is what I'm here to do. I'm here to create a fantasy that things aren't as bad as they are. And they are.
我明白这出于善意。但在马路那头的医院里，成千上万的人正在死去。而我却在这里给你端玛格丽特酒，因为我不得不这么做。因为我必须活着。那一刻我强烈地意识到：这就是我在这里要做的事。我在这里是为了制造一种“情况没那么糟”的幻象。但情况确实很糟。
What is essential about restaurants? Sure, they provide jobs, food, but so do grocery stores. This was a health crisis. Doctors, nurses-- sure, essential. But what is essential about an Asian fusion place in downtown Phoenix? All these things we suddenly started calling essential services, this wasn't some long-held, agreed-upon category. We just made all this up very recently. And even then, it was pretty random.
餐厅的“必要性”在哪里？当然，它们提供了工作、食物，但超市也能。这是一场健康危机。医生、护士——当然，是必要的。但菲尼克斯市中心那家亚洲融合餐厅有什么必要的？我们突然开始把所有这些东西称为“必要服务”，这根本不是什么长期达成共识的类别。我们最近才刚刚编造出这一切。即便如此，范围也很随机。
There was federal guidance on what services should be essential, but most states didn't follow the guidance. They either came up with their own list of essential services, or they had no guidance. So if you had a liquor store in Pennsylvania, you were not essential. But in New Jersey, you were. Construction workers, that was a controversial one in a number of states. Essential or not essential?
联邦政府对哪些服务应该是必要的有指导建议，但大多数州并没有照办。他们要么列出了自己的清单，要么干脆没有指导。所以如果你在宾夕法尼亚州有一家酒类商店，那不是必要的。但在新泽西州，就是。建筑工人，这在许多州是有争议的。必要还是不必要？
And then there are the ones that have a particularly local flavor, like flower shops. They were essential in Delaware. And in Arizona, golf courses, essential-- also restaurants. So Shelly's restaurant was open, and millions of restaurant workers performed their normal daily routines through a pandemic. Why? What essential service did they provide? Was this it? Restaurants were essential because they helped make things feel normal?
还有一些具有地方特色的，比如花店。它们在特拉华州是必要的。在亚利桑那州，高尔夫球场是必要的——餐厅也是。所以 Shelly 的餐厅开门了，数百万餐厅员工在疫情中重复着正常的日常例行公事。为什么？他们提供了什么必要服务？难道就是这个？餐厅是必要的，因为它们能帮助人们感觉到一切正常？
Once Shelly thought about her job this way-- she was to continue doing all the things she'd always done, she was essential so that other people could feel normal-- it was too much for her. The tradeoff she'd been making in her head, $25 tips in exchange for some long hours, some crap from customers, that tradeoff fell apart. She didn't want to be paid for the fantasy anymore. A few weeks later, a coworker was exposed to COVID, and Shelly walked out of the restaurant.
一旦 Shelly 从这个角度看待她的工作——她得继续做所有她以前做过的事，她是必要的，为了让别人觉得正常——这就让她无法承受了。她脑子里一直进行的交易，用长工时和顾客的垃圾话换取25美元的小费，那笔交易破裂了。她不想再为了幻象出卖自己了。几周后，一名同事感染了新冠，Shelly 直接走出了那家餐厅。
And then I never went back.
然后我就再也没回去过。
Oh, that was the end for you.
哦，那对你来说就是终点。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Shelly got unemployment, then picked up some film jobs, went back to school for film. She told me now she doesn't think she could ever go back to serving, even after the pandemic.
Shelly 领了失业救济，然后接了一些电影工作，重回学校学习电影。她告诉我，现在即使疫情结束，她也不认为自己能再回去当服务员了。
Do you feel like the actual job changed, or do you think it's that you changed? Like, has it become ugly, or was it always ugly?
你觉得是工作变了，还是你变了？它变得更糟糕了，还是它一直这么糟糕？
Yeah, I think that I changed more than the job changed. There's always been a certain amount of ugly that's been in the restaurant industry, especially-- sexual harassment has always been there. Verbal harassment has always been there. But it was like seeing it for the first time with new eyes. I saw a lack of kindness and courtesy, and it was constant.
是的，我觉得我改变的程度比工作改变的程度大。餐饮业一直都有一定程度的糟糕，特别是——性骚扰一直存在。口头骚扰也一直存在。但我像是第一次用新的眼睛去看这一切。我看到了缺乏善良和礼貌，而且这种缺失是持续性的。
Yeah. It's almost like people put on COVID goggles. And wearing the COVID goggles, they started to see their job differently.
是的。简直就像人们戴上了“新冠滤镜”。戴着这种滤镜，他们开始用不同的方式看待自己的工作。
Mm-hmm. I definitely saw my job differently with my COVID goggles for sure. That is what made it really ugly for me.
嗯。戴着我的“新冠滤镜”，我确实用不同的眼光看待我的工作了。这正是让它对我而言变得无比丑陋的原因。
Here's the image I have in my mind hearing Shelly talk about where she's at right now. I picture all the governors and mayors and council members sitting down to make their lists of essential services-- hospitals, grocery stores, restaurants, golf courses. And I picture Shelly doing the same. She's making her own list of all the things she considers essential-- her life, her health, her self-worth. And she's crossing off an item at the very bottom of her list, a $25 tip.
听着 Shelly 谈论她现在的处境，我脑海中浮现出一个画面。我看到所有州长、市长和议员坐下来制定他们的“必要服务清单”——医院、超市、餐厅、高尔夫球场。我想象 Shelly 也在做同样的事。她在列出她认为必要的东西——她的生命、健康、自尊。她划掉了清单最底下的那项：25美元的小费。
Coming up, quitters and the people who love them. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，是辞职者和爱他们的人。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续后播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. This week's show, we are talking to essential workers about what happened inside their jobs over the last year and a half, things nobody else knows. And we are marking these experiences down for posterity. So that as we move into the bright and quickly darkening future, we will do so with a shared understanding of what we have just been through.
这里是《美国生活》。我是 Chana Joffe-Walt，代替 Ira Glass 主持。本周节目，我们正在和必要行业员工谈论过去一年半里他们的工作内部发生了什么，那些没人知道的事情。我们正在为后人记录这些经历。这样当我们步入那光明而又迅速变暗的未来时，我们能对我们刚刚经历过的一切有一个共同的理解。
So far, we have 415 coffins, 3 bottles of Joy, and a $25 tip. We're going to be adding more to that list. And we will see what happens when people take stock one by one and wind up making some choices they never expected to make. That's what the second half of the show is about, quitters and the people they quit on. A record number of people are quitting their jobs, and they are all quitting on Miss Jordyn Rossingol.
到目前为止，我们有415口棺材，3瓶 Joy 洗洁精，和25美元的小费。我们要把更多的内容列入那份清单。我们来看看当人们一个个开始盘点，并最终做出他们从未预想过的选择时会发生什么。这就是节目后半段的主题，辞职者和被他们抛弃的人。现在创纪录的人数正在辞职，而且他们抛弃的都是 Jordyn Rossingol 小姐。
That's how it feels to her, anyway, which brings us to our next act, Teacher Number Four. Miss Jordyn's Child Development Center in northern Maine has lost 23 teachers since the pandemic began. 23. Most years, Miss Jordyn told me herself, maybe one or two teachers leave. So that's our next number for our ledger, 23. 23 disappearing teachers. Miss Jordyn says the first teacher, she left right away, March 2020. She was scared of germy kids. Then another went in April, a third in May. They left for other jobs.
反正她感觉就是这样，这也引出了我们的下一个单元，“四号老师”。Jordyn 小姐在缅因州北部的儿童发展中心自疫情开始以来已经流失了23名老师。23名。Jordyn 小姐本人告诉我，往年大概也就走一两个老师。所以这是我们账本上的下一个数字：23。23名消失的老师。Jordyn 小姐说第一个老师是立刻就走了，2020年3月。她害怕脏兮兮的孩子。然后另一个在四月走了，第三个在五月。她们辞职去干别的工作了。
And then in June, Miss Jordyn says, was teacher number 4.
然后在六月，Jordyn 小姐说，那是四号老师。
Shania. Ah, Shania was hands-down, the best teacher I've ever had in this program, ever. I could talk for hours about Shania.
Shania。啊，Shania 毫无疑问是我这个项目中遇到过的最好的老师，从来没有之一。我可以花几个小时聊 Shania。
Finding good teachers and then keeping them-- this has always been a problem in early childhood education. It's one of those areas that was already a bruise, and the pandemic came and just stomped on it until the bone was broken too. For Miss Jordan, teacher number 4, Shania Bell, that felt like the break. She can't get over it.
找到好老师然后留住她们——这是幼儿教育中一直以来的难题。这是那种本来就有淤青的伤口，而疫情过来直接踩在了上面，直到骨头也断了。对 Jordyn 小姐来说，四号老师 Shania Bell 的离去，就像是那致命一击。她无法忘怀。
And she's not joking about how much time she can spend lamenting this particular loss. Shania's ideas were fresh, she tells me. Her discipline was fair. Her lesson plans were thought-out. She was reliable, she was a fun coworker.
她并没有开玩笑，她确实能花很多时间感叹这一特定的损失。她告诉我，Shania 的想法很新鲜。她的纪律要求很公平。她的教案考虑得很周全。她很可靠，是个有趣的同事。
In meetings, when we'd have staff meetings, I would say, OK, your voice, I want you to have Shania voice, where they could be firm, but their voice was happy. In the morning, when you drop off your child, you want to hear, good morning, my friends.
在开员工会议时，我会说：“好的，我要你们拥有‘Shania 之声’，既坚定但听起来又很快乐。”早上当你送孩子过来时，你想听到：“早上好，我的朋友们。”
What kind of voice were people doing?
他们以前用的是什么样的声音？
Just like, oh. Good morning. How are you doing? Let's go. Get in. Come on. Oh. I know you're crying. Let's go. Just short. We had some teachers in the past who were just short. Come on, you're a big kid. Let's go. None of that. Like, no good morning, my sweet girl. Good morning, friends.
就像是，哦。早上好。你怎么样？走吧。进去。快点。哦。我知道你在哭。走吧。就那样，很生硬。过去我们有些老师真的很生硬。“快点，你是个大孩子了。走吧。”不是那样。没有“早上好，我甜美的女孩”，“早上好，朋友们”。
She did this calm-down method, because toddlers, toddlers get mad. And they don't know why they're mad all the time. And they're impulsive. And they want to bite or hit or run away. And she told them to blow up a balloon. And they would put their hands over their head while taking a deep breath, and they would hold it there like a balloon over their head. And then they would slowly let the air out and they would just go, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh. And they would sit by themselves. And she made a little balloon corner, is what she called it.
她有一个“冷静法”，因为蹒跚学步的孩子，他们总是会生气。他们并不总是知道为什么生气。他们很冲动。他们想咬人、打人或跑掉。她让他们吹气球。他们会把手放在头上同时深呼吸，他们会像气球一样放在头顶保持住。然后他们会慢慢把气排出来，发出“噗，噗，噗”的声音。然后他们会独自坐在一边。她说那是“气球角”。
And they still do it. I'll still say-- even my own daughter, Monroe. Monroe, I need you to do three balloons, please. And she'll take her three deep breaths. [INHALES] Puh, puh, puh, puh, puh. And she'll release them and they're calm. So, yeah. It's just-- she has a gift. She has a gift, just amazing. Amazing. Like, you can't teach it.
他们现在还会那样做。我甚至会对我的女儿 Monroe 说：“Monroe，我需要你吹三个气球，好吗？”她会深呼吸三次。（吸气声）“噗，噗，噗。”她释放出来，然后就冷静了。所以，是的。这就是——她有天赋。她有一种天赋，太棒了。惊人。那种你没法教的天赋。
See what I mean? When Miss Jordyn conceived of her early childhood center in her hometown, babies to kindergarten, she could picture it in her mind. But she says it wasn't until Shania showed up a couple of years ago, and she got to see her in a real classroom, that's when Miss Jordyn felt like, this is going to work.
明白我意思吗？当 Jordyn 小姐在家乡构思她的幼儿中心时——从婴儿到幼儿园——她脑子里有蓝图。但她说直到 Shania 两年前出现，她亲眼见到她在真实的教室里教学，Jordyn 小姐才感到：这事儿能成。
Shania told me for her, when she walked into Miss Jordyn's center, 21 years old, she was nervous in a way she had not been before. Because she felt like, this is it. This is the job I actually care about, and I don't want to mess it up. And she did love the job. But then--
Shania 告诉我，对她而言，当她21岁走进 Jordyn 小姐的中心时，她有一种前所未有的紧张。因为她觉得：就是这儿了。这是我真正关心的工作，我不想搞砸。她确实热爱这份工作。但随后——
2020 hit, and COVID hit. And for a little while, a lot of our kiddos weren't coming to school. And I was nervous, like, are we going to have to close? Am I not going to be getting paid for a little while? I don't know. There was just a lot of uncertainty.
2020年来了，疫情来了。有一阵子，很多孩子不来上学了。我很紧张，比如：我们会不会被迫关门？我有一段时间是不是拿不到工资？我不知道。有太多不确定性。
There was the time the owner, Miss Jordyn, asked everyone to hold off on getting paid, and their paychecks came in late. And the time Shania was pretty sure her paycheck came from Miss Jordyn's personal bank account. Shania began to feel like, wait, is there no cushion in this business? She'd never really thought about the business side of things before. But once she started to, she started to have some doubts. When a friend posted about a job at the local hardware store, Shania applied. Then she had to tell Miss Jordan.
有次老板 Jordyn 小姐请求大家暂缓领取工资，她们的薪水迟到了。还有次 Shania 非常确定她的工资是从 Jordyn 小姐的个人银行账户发出的。Shania 开始觉得，等等，这行业一点缓冲都没有吗？以前她从没想过生意层面的问题。但一旦她开始想，她就开始产生怀疑。当朋友发了一则当地五金店的工作招募时，Shania 投了简历。然后她不得不告诉 Jordyn。
So she came in my office and shut the door. And I knew that was bad when she shut the door.
所以她走进我的办公室，关上了门。她关门的时候我就知道大事不妙。
This is Miss Jordyn again.
又是 Jordyn 小姐。
And she just started crying. And she like, I was offered a job. That was the first time I ever cried when someone gave me their notice. I just lost it. [INAUDIBLE]
她就开始哭。她说有人给了她一份工作。这是我第一次听到有人提辞职时我跟着一起哭。我崩溃了。（听不清）
You started crying?
你开始哭了？
Yeah, instantly. Yeah. And she was just crying. She was like, Jordyn, I can't pay my bills. I can't afford to work here.
对，立刻。是的。她一直在哭。她说：“Jordyn，我没钱付账单。我付不起在这里工作的代价。”
This is obvious, but deserves saying anyway. So many of the people we call essential workers do not make a lot of money. They're overwhelmingly low-wage workers. About half the people in this country who make less than $15 an hour work in fields we now call essential. So you can be the very best at running the grill or cleaning the office building or managing rude customers at the restaurant, you can be the star teacher, teacher number 4, Shania, and still only make an average of $11 or $12 an hour-- and no health care.
这很显而易见，但还是值得一说。许多我们称之为“必要员工”的人赚不到多少钱。他们绝大多数是低薪工人。在这个国家，时薪低于15美元的人中，大约有一半在从事我们现在所说的“必要行业”。所以，你可以是烤架上的高手，或者是办公室的清洁达人，或者是餐厅里应对难缠顾客的高手，你可以是王牌教师，四号老师 Shania，但依然只能拿每小时11或12美元的平均工资——而且没有医疗保障。
Miss Jordyn barely makes enough from tuition to cover her expenses. But she's reluctant to raise rates on families, because she knows many parents can't afford to pay. And she knows from experience that if she goes too high, families are going to pull their kids all together. When Shania talked to Miss Jordyn-- and when she talked to me-- about leaving her job, she could not bring herself to say the word quit. She told Miss Jordyn, I have to get done.
Jordyn 小姐从学费里赚到的钱勉强够支付开支。但她不愿给家庭加价，因为她知道许多父母负担不起。而且她凭经验知道，如果她收费太高，家庭就会把孩子全都转走。当 Shania 跟 Jordyn 小姐谈及离职时——包括她跟我谈起时——她无法让自己说出“辞职”这个词。她告诉 Jordyn 小姐：“我不得不结束这一切。”
I knew that she was going to try everything to pay me more. But I knew that everything she was trying to do possibly wasn't going to work out in the end, just because she really couldn't afford to do that.
我知道她会尝试一切办法给我加工资。但我知道她尝试做的一切最终可能都不会成功，仅仅是因为她真的负担不起。
And you knew that.
你明白这一点。
Yeah, and I knew that. And I understood.
是的，我知道。我理解。
Miss Jordyn did do all those things. She pleaded, we'll figure something out. Just give me more time. And she tried a technique that I think is maybe only applicable in a small town. When Shania said where she was going, Miss Jordyn shook her head.
Jordyn 小姐确实做了所有那些事。她恳求道：“我们会想出办法的。再给我一点时间。”她还用了一个我觉得可能只有在小镇上才有效的方法。当 Shania 说她要去哪儿时，Jordyn 小姐摇了摇头。
I said you're going to hate it. [LAUGHS]
我说你会恨那儿的。（笑声）
You told her that?
你对她这么说？
I said-- yeah. I was like, I love you, and I want you to be happy, but you're going to hate it. And I know the boss and the owner of it. And I said he won't love you the way I love you. I'll tell you that. And she's like, I know. I know. And I also thought like, she's going to hate that. She's going to come back.
我说——是的。我说：“我爱你，我希望你快乐，但你会恨那儿的。我认识那儿的老板和主人。我告诉她，他不会像我爱你那样爱你。我保证。”她说：“我知道。我知道。”而且我也想，她会讨厌那儿的。她会回来的。
So Shania left, and Miss Jordyn waited for her to return. In the early child care world, there were two somewhat distinct phases of the pandemic. There was the beginning, in which child care centers lost money, even as their work became labeled essential. And then there's this moment now, where what was already a chronic problem of teacher turnover has become so much worse, because the industry can't compete.
所以 Shania 走了，Jordyn 小姐等着她回来。在幼教领域，疫情有两个截然不同的阶段。第一阶段，托儿所亏钱，即使她们的工作被贴上了“必要”的标签。然后是现在的时刻，教师流动这一长期的慢性问题变得更严重了，因为这个行业缺乏竞争力。
Places like Walmart, Home Depot, FedEx, grocery store chains like Kroger kept making money over the pandemic. Amazon made record profits. Child care centers did not. So teachers are leaving for jobs at Amazon or Dunkin' Donuts or grocery stores that can pay them more and sometimes give them health benefits. A woman in Ohio who owns a child care center told me, even the amusement parks can pay better than we can right now.
像沃尔玛、家得宝、联邦快递、Kroger 这样的超市连锁在疫情期间持续赚钱。亚马逊创下了利润纪录。托儿所没有。所以老师们纷纷离开，去亚马逊、Dunkin' Donuts 或超市上班，因为那些地方能支付更高的工资，有时还提供健康福利。俄亥俄州一位托儿所老板告诉我，现在连游乐园付的钱都比我们多。
When Miss Jordyn lost Shania, teacher number 4 of 23, she allowed a thought that has been sitting uncomfortably to the forefront ever since. What if I can never keep someone like Shania? What if no one ever believes this is valuable?
当 Jordyn 小姐失去 Shania，即23人中的第4号老师时，她一直以来感到不舒服的一个想法浮上了心头：如果我永远留不住像 Shania 这样的人怎么办？如果没人相信这事儿有价值怎么办？
I feel like I'm constantly trying to prove myself that what I'm doing is important. I have a college degree in education. People don't know. People don't know what we do. Like, how could it cost so much? Aren't you guys just like, coloring and eating goldfish all day with them? Like, no. No.
我觉得我一直在向自己证明我做的事情很重要。我有教育学学位。人们根本不知道。人们不知道我们做了什么。就像，怎么会花这么多钱？你们不就是带着孩子涂涂画画、整天吃小金鱼饼干吗？不是的。不。
I make lesson plans for every single classroom, infant up to the school-age program. There's so many regulations that we have to follow. There's a schedule. There's a meal plan. There's trainings that my staff have to do. We run this like a school. The only difference is that there's no public funding for us.
我为每一个班级都制作教案，从婴儿到学龄计划。我们要遵守的法规太多了。有时间表，有配餐计划。我的员工必须接受培训。我们像经营学校一样经营这里。唯一的区别是，我们没有公共资金支持。
Why is it that essential workers happen to be some of the lowest paid workers in the country? How could a job that is so valuable be paid so little? There are some standard explanations you will hear. Many essential jobs do not require extra credentials or a lot of education. There's a lot of available labor to do these jobs. In other words, they are low-paid because they are, quote, "low-skilled" jobs.
为什么必要行业员工恰好是这个国家薪水最低的群体？一个如此有价值的工作，怎么报酬如此之低？你会听到一些标准的解释。许多必要工作不需要额外资历或高学历。有很多劳动力可以胜任这些工作。换句话说，它们之所以低薪，是因为它们是所谓的“低技能”工作。
But also, one thing that unites this broad category of low-paid essential jobs, and almost everyone you've heard from in this show, is not the kind of work they're doing, but who is doing it-- Black people, Latino people, immigrants, women, and all the people who cover more than one of those categories. 95% of child care workers are women-- white women, like Shania and Miss Jordyn, and many women of color. Almost half of child care workers are people of color. The field is much more racially and linguistically diverse than K through 12 teachers. And the people in it make much less money.
但还有一件事将这一大类低薪必要工作联系在一起，也是你们在节目中听到的几乎每个人共有的，不是他们从事的工作种类，而是谁在从事——黑人、拉丁裔、移民、女性，以及所有属于不止一个这类群体的人。95%的幼教工作者是女性——像 Shania 和 Jordyn 小姐那样的白人女性，以及许多有色人种女性。几乎一半的幼教工作者是有色人种。该领域在种族和语言上的多元化程度远超中小学教师。但这些人的薪水却低得多。
The pandemic gave child care an official stamp of essentialness in this singular moment in history when it is more clear than it has ever been and may ever be again that schools and child care are essential to the functioning of literally everything. But Miss Jordyn's work and the people doing that work may never be valued enough for her to secure more funding or for her to get Shania back.
疫情给托儿服务盖上了“必要”的官方印章，在这个历史上独特的时刻，学校和托儿服务对一切运作的必要性比以往任何时候都更加清晰。但 Jordyn 小姐的工作以及从事该工作的人，可能永远不会得到足够的重视，以至于她获得更多资金，或者留住 Shania。
Miss Jordyn and Shania live in a town of 8,000 people. So when Shania left, she went all the way to a job across the street. She parks in the same spot she did when she worked at Miss Jordyn's. Miss Jordyn told me, I see her all the time.
Jordyn 小姐和 Shania 住在一个只有8000人的小镇。所以 Shania 离职后，她去了一份街对面的工作。她停的车位和她在 Jordyn 小姐那儿上班时一样。Jordyn 小姐告诉我：“我经常看到她。”
She came by like, every day after work, her first week over there. And she was like, well, it's not the same. It's definitely not the same. She's like, I didn't think I was going to have to work Saturdays, and now I have to work every Saturday all summer. And I said, weird, your old boss never made you work a Saturday. [LAUGHTER]
她在那儿工作的第一周，几乎每天下班后都过来。她说：“嗯，不一样。真的完全不一样。她说，我没想到我竟然还得在周六工作，现在整个夏天我每个周六都要工作。”我说：“奇怪，你以前的老板可从来不让你周六工作。”（笑声）
Oh, Jordyn.
哦，Jordyn。
Yeah. So we'd tease each other about that and stuff. And then she's come to have lunch with me a couple of times during her lunch break. The other day, I was working on a project, and I needed paint. I went over there. She was working behind the paint counter. She mixed my paint for me.
是的。所以我们就拿这事开玩笑之类的。然后她还抽空来跟我吃过几次午饭。前几天，我在做一个项目，需要颜料。我过去找她。她正在油漆柜台后面忙活。她帮我调色。
And as I watched her mix paint, I was like, I can't believe this is what you're doing. Like, you are so talented and so gifted and-- not that mixing paint isn't important. But like, that's what you're doing? She has a gift that you can't teach. It just kills me to watch her do something that is not what her gift is and her passion.
当我看着她调色时，我心想：我不敢相信这就是你在做的事。你如此有才华、如此有天赋，而且——我不是说调色不重要。但是，这就是你在做的？她有一种天赋，是教不出来的。看着她去做那些不是她天赋所在、也不是她热情所在的事情，真是让我难受。
One thing economists will say about economic moments like this, when a lot of people are quitting their jobs, they'll say, it's a good thing. High quits numbers equals optimism. People are going back to school, they're going for that dream job. People feel secure enough to look around a little for what they really want to do.
经济学家在谈论这种经济时刻（即大量人口辞职时）会说，这是好事。高离职率等于乐观。人们重返校园，去追求那份梦想的工作。人们感到足够安全，可以四处寻找他们真正想做的事情。
This is obviously not an example of that. This is an example of a market that does not work. This is an example of a talented person who's drawn to a job that is essential that she's not doing, because it does not pay enough.
这显然不是那个例子。这是市场失灵的例子。这是一个有天赋的人被一份必要工作吸引，但她却做不了，因为它支付的薪水不够。
Act 4. There are people who are quitting who are happy about it. There are people who are mad, confused about what they want. Of course, there's the whole range. One thing I found interesting is that for many people, there was often one moment that set things in motion for them a while back, some symbol of something just being off in their job. And then it's like, these symbols just sat next to them for months, kind of haunting them until they could not deal anymore.
第四单元。有辞职并对此感到开心的人。有生气的人，对想要什么感到困惑的人。当然，这涵盖了整个范围。我发现有趣的一点是，对于许多人来说，通常有一个时刻，早在一年前就启动了一切，那是某种象征，代表着他们工作中有什么地方不对劲。然后就像是，这些象征在他们身边停留了几个月，像幽灵一样缠着他们，直到他们再也无法忍受。
They found themselves doing something they never planned to do. Sometimes that was quitting, but there were some other approaches as well. So for our last story, I want to tell you about some of those symbols and then what happened next. Our last number-- it's also our biggest number in the whole show-- 12 million. Act 4, 12 Million Thank You Meals. This one I heard about from a guy in Flint, Michigan.
他们发现自己做了从未计划过的事。有时是辞职，但也有其他方法。所以对于最后一个故事，我想告诉你们一些这样的象征，以及接下来发生了什么。我们的最后一个数字——这也是节目中最大的数字——1200万。第四单元：1200万份“感谢套餐”。这是我从密歇根州弗林特市的一个人那里听到的。
My name is Flato Alexander, F-L-A-T-O.
我的名字叫 Flato Alexander，F-L-A-T-O。
Flato is 61 years old. He's a Black man, wakes up every morning at 4:00 AM, walks to work, McDonald's, opens the store, cooks sausage, eggs, pancakes. He's in the back on his own, sometimes for many hours. He doesn't mind. He enjoys working alone. When he's at home, Flato will spend a lot of time helping out neighbors, removing snow, cutting grass. He enjoys that too, although he did mention he's a person who sometimes has a hard time saying no.
Flato今年61岁。他是一名黑人，每天早上4点起床，步行上班，在麦当劳开店，烹饪香肠、鸡蛋、煎饼。他一个人在后厨，有时好几个小时。他不介意。他喜欢独自工作。在家时，Flato 会花很多时间帮邻居除雪、修剪草坪。他也喜欢做这些，尽管他提到过，他有时很难说“不”。
When I asked Flato what the pandemic was like for him, that's when he started telling me about how last spring, McDonald's began offering free food, Egg McMuffins.
当我问 Flato 疫情对他而言是什么样时，他开始向我讲起去年春天，麦当劳开始提供免费食物，满福堡（Egg McMuffins）。
At first I seen the commercial. And I'm like, wow, they're fitting to give away an egg muffin meal to essential workers.
起初我看到了广告。心想：哇，他们准备送一份满福堡套餐给必要行业员工。
These are the most important meals we've ever served. Through May 5th, we'll be feeding first responders and health care workers Thank You Meals for free.
这是我们服务过的最重要的餐点。到5月5日前，我们将为急救人员和医护人员免费提供“感谢套餐”。
Remember this? I realized watching a bunch of these commercials, I'd somehow forgotten how completely everyone threw themselves in to breathlessly praising essential workers, two words most of us had never heard used together before. All of a sudden, they were everywhere. It's like we invented this category of worker to thank them.
还记得这个吗？看着这一连串广告，我意识到我不知怎么地忘记了所有人是如何倾其所有，不遗余力地赞美“必要行业员工”的，这是两个词，大多数人在那之前从没听过连在一起使用。突然之间，它们无处不在。就好像我们发明了这个工作类别来感谢他们。
We'll be proudly feeding you Thank You Meals for free. It's our honor to serve you.
我们将自豪地为你们免费提供“感谢套餐”。为您服务是我们的荣幸。
Anyway, Flato saw that commercial and was like, oh, that'll be me serving you.
反正，Flato 看了那则广告，心想：哦，那就是我在为你们服务。
And I'm like, oh, Lord, we fitting to get ready to be busy. That's my first thought. And the workers came, people from hospitals, nurses. They came and got the food.
我心想，天哪，我们准备要忙了。这是我的第一念头。工人们来了，医院里的人，护士。他们过来领了食物。
Now, I thought Flato was sharing this as a moment of pride, being part of this. But no. This moment, handing out free Thank You Meals, it was the start of something for him.
现在，我以为 Flato 分享这个是出于自豪，作为其中的一分子。但不是。那一刻，分发免费的“感谢套餐”，对他来说是某件事的开始。
Well, to be honest with you, I didn't like it. I didn't understand it. Because we here working, and you want to make some food and give it to somebody. We couldn't go nowhere and get nothing free.
嗯，说实话，我不喜欢。我不明白。因为我们在这工作，而他们想做点饭送给别人。我们哪里也去不了，什么也领不到免费的。
You weren't getting the free food that was for the essential workers?
你们没领到那些给必要行业员工的免费食物吗？
Yeah, that's for the essential workers.
是的，那是给必要行业员工的。
Weren't you guys essential workers?
难道你们不是必要行业员工吗？
Yeah. So why you don't come up with something for us to have?
是的。那为什么你们不为我们想点东西呢？
McDonald's gave away 12 million Thank You Meals to frontline workers. After two weeks, they stopped, but not without putting out one more commercial.
麦当劳给一线员工送出了1200万份“感谢套餐”。两周后，他们停止了，但也投放了最后一个广告。
It was an honor to meet you, an honor to thank you, and it was our honor to serve you.
遇见你们是我们的荣幸，感谢你们是我们的荣幸，为你们服务更是我们的荣幸。
Business went back to normal, but Flato kept returning to the experience in his mind. How much did that cost? All of a sudden, they have so much money for that?
生意回到了正常，但 Flato 的心思一直回到那段经历上。那得花多少钱？突然之间，他们有这么多钱花在上面？
They was giving it-- giving free food away. If you got the audacity to waste millions of dollars on giving somebody some food, take some of that money and make a difference with one of us. You making a difference with other people, but you still ignoring your workers. So I didn't understand it. I guess that was probably one of their shareholders meeting to come up with that idea.
他们在送免费食物。如果你有胆量浪费几百万美元去给别人送食物，拿出一部分钱改善一下我们其中一个人的待遇吧。你们改善了别人的境遇，却依然无视自己的员工。所以我不明白。我想那大概是他们的股东大会想出来的主意。
Flato talked a lot about the shareholders for McDonald's, the big corporation, and also about the franchise owner, the people who own his McDonald's and about a dozen or so other stores. He says he barely saw them during the pandemic. The higher-ups, they rarely came to the store. He'd always noticed it. But handing out the Thank You Meals for health care workers, he noticed it more.
Flato 谈了很多关于麦当劳股东、大公司，以及加盟商的事，就是那些拥有他这家麦当劳以及其他十几家店的人。他说疫情期间他几乎没见过他们。高层很少来店里。他一直注意到了这点。但在分发给医护人员的“感谢套餐”时，他注意得更多了。
You scratching your head like, wow. No appreciation gets shown towards us. Show some type of appreciation towards the ones that's doing some work. That's what I mean. It's not no jealous thing, it's common sense. It's like a show of unconcern.
你挠着头想：哇。我们没得到任何感谢。对那些努力工作的人展示一下感激吧。我就是这个意思。这跟嫉妒没关系，这是常识。这是一种漠不关心。
The feeling that you're describing, did that start in the last year for you?
你描述的那种感觉，是去年才开始的吗？
Yeah. Yeah. To be honest with you, you are 1,000% right. It sure has. Come to the company and say good job. You guys are doing a good job. I ain't heard that this year. Thank you all for coming to work during this time.
是的。说实话，你完全说对了。确实是。公司应该来对我们说：“干得好。你们表现很棒。”今年我可没听到这句话。“谢谢你们在此期间坚持上班。”
What would it have meant to you if you had?
如果你听到了，这对你意味着什么？
It would've meant a lot. It would've been a very touching thing for somebody to let you know that they have the slightest respect for your life and your livelihood. Because not showing-- a sense of unconcern to people, it's not a good feeling. It's like having a relative that won't speak to you. It makes you sad.
那会意味着很多。如果有人能让你知道他们对你的生命和生计怀有一丁点的尊重，那将是非常感人的事。因为不表现出这种尊重——对人漠不关心，这感觉不好。就像有个亲戚永远不跟你说话一样。让人难过。
I thought that was such a fitting way to describe something I'd heard from a lot of people who worked through the pandemic, a feeling that while they had no choice to come to work, the people who were making all the choices-- if they had to work, how much they'd get paid, how safe they'd be-- those people appeared completely indifferent-- callous, even, like a relative who won't speak to you. A server at a pizza restaurant in Texas, Ashley Baker, told me the owner used to come in all the time. And then he vanished.
我觉得这描述得太贴切了，我从许多疫情期间上班的人那里听到了同样的感觉，一种他们别无选择只能上班，但那些做决定的人——如果你必须工作，工资多少，安全与否——这些人看起来完全漠不关心——甚至麻木不仁，就像一个永远不跟你说话的亲戚。德克萨斯州一家披萨店的服务员 Ashley Baker 告诉我，老板以前经常过来。然后他消失了。
He did. He literally stopped coming to the restaurant. He literally just went AWOL. As soon as there was news saying that COVID was in El Paso, he literally disappeared.
他确实消失了。他真的停止来餐厅了。他真的擅离职守了。一旦有新闻说新冠到了埃尔帕索，他就直接消失了。
When he showed back up months later, they were all relieved to have someone in charge, to answer their questions.
当几个月后他再出现时，他们都松了口气，觉得终于有人负责回答他们的问题了。
But I do remember one thing that really struck a nerve with me was that he changed his vehicle to a Corvette. And I remember that kind of struck a nerve in me. Because I'm like, wow, you're paying us minimum wage. And you want people to come in on time and stuff, but you're over here-- you have the luxury of not coming in. And you have the ability to get a brand new car. That was the moment where things just set in.
但我记得有一件事真的触动了我的神经，那就是他换了一辆雪佛兰克尔维特跑车。我记得这件事真的刺痛了我。因为我心想，哇，你只付我们最低工资。你希望员工准时到岗之类的，但你呢——你有不来店里的奢侈。而且你有能力买一辆全新的车。就在那一刻，所有事情都真相大白了。
For Flato, it was the 12 million Thank You Meals. That was the symbol for him, now glowing neon. It put all the other parts of his job in a less-acceptable light. For Ashley, it was the Corvette. For employees at a McDonald's in California, perhaps it was when they raised concerns about the lack of PPE. And they say their bosses told them to use coffee filters and doggie diapers for masks.
对 Flato 来说，那是1200万份“感谢套餐”。那是他的标志，现在正发出霓虹般的光芒。它让工作中所有其他部分看起来都不那么能接受了。对 Ashley 来说，那是克尔维特。对加州一家麦当劳的员工来说，也许是当他们提出关于缺乏 PPE 的担忧时，老板叫他们用咖啡滤纸和狗尿布做口罩。
For a guy I met outside an Amazon warehouse, it was when he says he was fired four times for having COVID. Four times. This was a thing, apparently, at Amazon. People would tell their bosses they had COVID, or they got exposed to COVID, and then they'd get fired. Later, they would hear it was an HR mistake, and they were welcome to appeal, get their job back, but not always the weeks or sometimes months of lost wages.
我见过一个亚马逊仓库外的人，他说因为得了新冠，他被开除了四次。四次。这似乎是亚马逊的一件事。人们告诉老板他们得了新冠，或者接触过新冠患者，然后他们就被开除了。后来，他们会听说那是人力资源的错误，欢迎申诉，拿回工作，但没法拿回因缺勤而损失的数周甚至数月工资。
And for Ashley's manager at the pizza place, a woman named Soliris Morales, the Corvette pissed her off. But the real sign for her was when the restaurant cut back her hours, and she became eligible for unemployment.
对于 Ashley 在披萨店的经理 Solaris Morales 来说，克尔维特让她很生气。但对她来说，真正的信号是餐厅削减了她的工时，她变得有资格领取失业救济时。
I was like, how can I be making more on unemployment than my actual job? I mean, how can it be possible that they gave us all that unemployment and we're still making like-- what's the minimum wage in Texas, $7.25? Like, how?
我当时心想：怎么我拿失业救济金比干我的正职工作拿的钱还多？我是说，他们发了那么多救济金，而我们赚的——德克萨斯州的最低工资是多少，7.25美元？怎么可能？
And what lesson did you take from that?
你从中学到了什么教训？
That your boss never cares for you. [LAUGHS] I don't know.
你的老板根本不在乎你。（笑声）我不知道。
Yeah.
是的。
These things just sat nearby as they did their jobs, nagging-- a Corvette, being fired four times, $7.25 an hour. Flato at McDonald's, he was handing out those Thank You Meals more than a year ago. He's still mad about it. He's mad about a lot of things-- that they never got hazard pay, sick pay, paid time off, health care.
当他们上班时，这些事情就悬在身边，不停地唠叨——一辆克尔维特，被开除四次，每小时7.25美元。Flato 在麦当劳，他分发那些“感谢套餐”是一年多前的事了。他现在还在为此生气。他为很多事生气——他们从来没拿到过危险津贴、病假工资、带薪假期、医疗保险。
The owner-operator of Flato's McDonald's says he showed his appreciation by raising wages during the pandemic. But Flato's wage is another thing that just makes him angry. He went from $11 to $12 an hour. He wants more. But the one thing Flato talked about more than any other was the fact that the franchise owner, and the people who work with him, did not come by. And when they did, they did not appear to actually see them.
Flato 的麦当劳加盟商说，他通过在疫情期间涨工资表达了谢意。但 Flato 的工资又是另一件让他生气的事。他的时薪从11美元涨到了12美元。他想要更多。但 Flato 谈论最多的一件事是：加盟商和那些与他共事的人没来过。即使他们来了，看起来也并没有真正看见他们。
No appreciation gets shown towards us. They don't know our name when they come in the building. Seemed like they showed no concern.
我们没得到任何感激。他们进门时根本不知道我们的名字。看起来他们一点也不关心。
That's interesting, because I feel like appreciating essential workers is the one thing that we did do. Like, most places didn't pay hazard pay or higher wages or health care. But like, there was so much thank you essential workers, we appreciate you and clapping for you, and commercials. But none of that felt like anything to you?
这很有意思，因为我觉得感谢必要行业员工是我们确实做过的一件事。就像大多数地方没发危险津贴、涨工资或提供医保。但到处都是“感谢必要行业员工”、“我们感激你们”还有为你鼓掌、做广告。但这些对你来说什么都不是吗？
No. Not really. My mother always said when you come into somebody's home, you're supposed to say, hey, how you doing? You're supposed to speak.
没有。真的什么都不是。我妈妈总说，当你走进别人家时，你应该说：“嘿，你怎么样？”你应该说话。
Yeah. You didn't want an ad. You wanted your actual human boss to come and say thank you.
是的。你不需要广告。你想要你真实的、人类的老板过来亲口说声谢谢。
Yeah, get everybody together in the lobby and tell us how you feel. That would be fine. That would be fine. That would be excellent for me. It've made me happy as hell.
是的，把大伙儿聚在大厅，告诉我们你的感受。那就可以了。那就可以了。那对我来说太完美了。我会高兴得不得了。
Ashley and Solaris at the pizza restaurant, they quit. The guy I met at the Amazon warehouse, he was being pitched on a union. A group of current and former employees are now trying to organize one at the Staten Island warehouse. And Flato did something he has never done his entire working career. Recently, when his coworkers started talking about striking, he joined. It felt like not him.
Ashley 和 Solaris 在披萨店辞职了。我在亚马逊仓库遇到那个哥们，他正在被动员加入工会。一群现任和前任员工现在正试图在史坦顿岛仓库组织一个。而 Flato 做了他职业生涯中从未做过的事。最近，当同事们开始谈论罢工时，他加入了。感觉这不像平时的他。
Yeah, it was new for me. It was very new. And there was so many people out. It was just-- [LAUGHS] actually, it was really nice. I mean, people was everywhere.
是的，这对我来说是新鲜事。非常新鲜。而且有那么多人出来。简直是——（笑声）事实上，感觉真的很好。我是说，人们到处都是。
Did you hold a sign?
你举牌子了吗？
No, I didn't get a chance to. And it's just sad that we have to stand outside and yell and scream and say, yeah, we want this, we want that-- when you should be sitting down and trying to come up with a plan for this to happen for us.
没，我没机会。而且让人难过的是我们不得不站在外面大喊大叫，说：“是的，我们要这个，我们要那个”——而他们本应该坐下来，试着为我们制定一个计划。
Did you ever expect that you would make it to 61 years old and suddenly become a guy who goes to strikes?
你有没有想过你到了61岁，突然变成了一个会去罢工的人？
Well, you only can slap a person so many times. And you only can do a person wrong so many times. Imagine you got all these jobs paying $19, $20 an hour, and some of them is giving you a $300 signing bonus. And like an idiot, I still sit here and walk to the golden arches.
嗯，人最多只能被打耳光这么多次。你做错事也只能做这么多次。想象一下，外面所有这些工作都付19、20美元一小时，有些还给你300美元签约奖金。而像个傻瓜一样，我还坐在这儿，走到金拱门（麦当劳）。
Flato doesn't want to quit. The McDonald's is close to his house-- he has no transportation. He can walk to work. He likes the people he works with, some of them he's worked with for many years. And he likes the work. He doesn't want to change. He wants the job to change. He wants it to be less thankless.
Flato 不想辞职。这家麦当劳离他家很近——他没交通工具。他只能走着去上班。他喜欢共事的那些人，有些人他已经共事很多年了。他喜欢这份工作。他不想改变。他想让工作本身发生改变。他想让这份工作不那么让人觉得“毫无感激”。
So many of the industries we deemed essential now seem to be in some sort of chaos. Restaurants are open now but not for dinner, because there's not enough staff. Health care workers are quitting their jobs, election officials are bailing, and school superintendents from America's three largest school systems have all quit. And things that never really worked that great before seem to be truly breaking down. I called JetBlue the other day to change a reservation, and the recording said, the current wait time is 299 minutes. Some food chains are actually raising wages-- Chipotle, Olive Garden. McDonald's is raising wages at its corporate stores-- to a small share of actual McDonald's stores, but still. Support for labor unions is the highest it's been in years.
我们认定为“必要”的许多行业似乎都陷入了某种混乱。餐厅现在开业了但不供晚餐，因为人手不够。医疗工作者正在辞职，选举官员在逃避，美国三大校区的总监全都辞职了。那些本来就没怎么运作好的东西似乎真的在分崩离析。前几天我给捷蓝航空打电话改签，录音说：“当前等待时间是299分钟。”一些餐饮连锁实际上正在涨工资——Chipotle, Olive Garden。麦当劳正在其直营店涨工资——虽然只占实际麦当劳门店的一小部分，但还在进行中。劳工工会的支持率是多年来的最高点。
Every week or so lately, I see a picture online posted outside a store or restaurant announcing that no one works there anymore. Like this one scotch-taped to the door that reads, "Attention Chipotle customers. We're overworked, understaffed, and underappreciated. Almost the entire staff and management have walked out of here until further notice." Or another, "we are closed indefinitely, because Dollar General doesn't pay a living wage or treat their employees with respect." I've never seen anything like it. Each sign, it seems like a whole group of employees just spontaneously and collectively decided they were done.
最近每隔一周左右，我就会在网上看到一张照片，那是贴在商店或餐厅外的公告，宣布那里没人上班了。比如这张用透明胶带贴在门上的：“致 Chipotle 的顾客：我们工作过度、人手不足，而且缺乏感谢。几乎全体员工和管理层已离职，直至另行通知。”或者另一张：“本店无限期关闭，因为 Dollar General 不付生活工资，也不尊重员工。”我从未见过这样的事。每一张公告，似乎都是一群员工自发地、集体地决定他们干够了。
But you know something happened at some point before now. Some shift started with, say, a Corvette, or with 12 million Thank You Meals. One sign posted on a McDonald's drive-through menu reads, "We are short-staffed. Please be patient with the staff that did show up. No one wants to work anymore." Or another, also from a different McDonald's, with a different perspective. It reads, "We are closed because I am quitting, and I hate this job."
但你知道在现在之前，某个时刻肯定发生过什么。某种转变始于，比如说，一辆克尔维特，或者1200万份“感谢套餐”。贴在麦当劳得来速菜单上的一张公告写着：“我们人手不足。请对留下的员工保持耐心。没人想上班了。”或者另一张，同样来自不同的麦当劳，但视角不同。它写着：“我们关闭了，因为我要辞职，而且我讨厌这份工作。”
People quit jobs for all sorts of reasons, and there are a lot of people debating why so many are doing it right now. So I'd like to just make sure this one possibility is on the table alongside all the others. That a good number of people worked through a life-threatening pandemic feeling unseen by the very people who are supposed to care for them, feeling, as Flato did, like they have a relative who will not speak to them.
人们辞职的原因各式各样，而且有很多人在争论为什么现在这么多人辞职。所以我只想确保这个可能性被摆在桌面上，和其他原因并列：很多人在冒着生命危险的疫情中工作，却感到被那些本应关照他们的人完全无视了，就像 Flato 那样，觉得自己有个永远不跟自己说话的亲戚。
My favorite sign is from a Wendy's in North Carolina. It reads, "We all quit. CLOSED." in capital letters. And then in the corner of the sign, someone scrawled, "Bye, Alisa" with a smiley face next to it.
我最喜欢的一张公告来自北卡罗来纳州的一家温迪汉堡（Wendy's）。上面写着：“我们全辞职了。关门。”用的是大写字母。然后在公告的一角，有人随手涂鸦写着：“拜拜，Alisa”，旁边还有一个笑脸。
[MUSIC - "WORK TO DO" BY THE ISLEY BROTHERS]
（音乐 - The Isley Brothers 的《WORK TO DO》）
Today's show was produced by Bim Adewunmi and edited by our Executive Editor, Emanuele Berry. The people who put our show together today include Susan Burton, Aviva DeKorngeld, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Lina Mitsitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alyssa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Chloee Weiner, and Diane Wu. Our Managing Editor is Sara Abdurrahman, Senior Editor, David Kestenbaum.
今天的节目由 Bim Adewunmi 制作，由我们的执行编辑 Emanuele Berry 编辑。今天参与制作的人员包括 Susan Burton, Aviva DeKorngeld, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Lina Mitsitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alyssa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Chloee Weiner 和 Diane Wu。我们的管理编辑是 Sara Abdurrahman，高级编辑 David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks today to Rachel Lissy, Jennifer Klein, Diana Ramirez at One Fair Wage, Kate Wells, Zoe Clark, Lea Austin and Penelope Whitney, Darrick Hamilton, Robert Williams, Anne Helen Peterson, Zoé Samudzi, Gina Ginn, Tonya Breslow, Betsey Stevenson, and all the other people who spoke to me about their essential jobs. And also thanks to the excellent reporters who have focused on them in their stories, especially Eliza Shapiro, Heather Long, and Annie Lowry.
特别感谢今天的 Rachel Lissy, Jennifer Klein, Diana Ramirez（来自 One Fair Wage）, Kate Wells, Zoe Clark, Lea Austin 和 Penelope Whitney, Darrick Hamilton, Robert Williams, Anne Helen Peterson, Zoé Samudzi, Gina Ginn, Tonya Breslow, Betsey Stevenson，以及所有与我谈论其必要工作的其他人。还要感谢那些在报道中关注他们的优秀记者，特别是 Eliza Shapiro, Heather Long 和 Annie Lowry。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks to my boss, Ira Glass. He has this special way of testing a microphone, always the same for the last 25 years doing the show. Puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh.
我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以免费流媒体收听我们超过700集的档案节目。《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。感谢我的老板 Ira Glass。他测试麦克风有一种特殊的方式，25年来做节目一直没变过。噗，噗，噗，噗，噗，噗，噗，噗。
We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我们下周会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "WORK TO DO" BY THE ISLEY BROTHERS]
（音乐 - The Isley Brothers 的《WORK TO DO》）